you're invited on february 27th to throw
the most sought after oscar viewing
party in town i'm katie lee and i have
the tips recipes and ideas to show you
how
whether your party is for a couple of
friends or you're hosting a gathering
for many it's a good idea to start early
by sending out invitations
my key ingredient to a successful party
fabulous food
since this is an oscar viewing party
it's important to serve foods that don't
require a knife and fork since most of
the eating is going to take place right
in front of the television one thing i
always like to serve at parties are my
deviled eggs with caviar so i take a
ziploc baggie and fill it with my
filling
and then just snip the end off and i
instantly have a pastry bag
and then i just use that to fill the
eggs
and it makes it nice and neat there's no
mess here
and then i'm gonna top it off with just
a little bit of caviar right on top of
the egg and it just looks so pretty
bon appetit
it's oscar night so instead of a boring
cheese and cracker platter how about a
gouda and goat cheese pimento spread and
it's super easy and you can do it the
day before and put it in the
refrigerator this just goes in the food
processor gouda goat cheese mayonnaise
pimentos some pickle relish it's really
really delicious and then just serve it
with some crackers and crudite
and it's beautiful elegant oh and so
delicious
the oscars are the biggest movie event
of the year and what would show night be
without some popcorn it's a chili orange
kettle corn all i did was add to my
popcorn some chili powder a little sugar
and salt while it was popping and then
the secret ingredient the finishing
touch is some orange zest
citrus zest can really brighten up
flavors it makes everything taste good
i have to do equality control
delicious
the oscars is the perfect night to serve
champagne at the academy's governor's
ball winners nominees and presenters
will all be sipping on this delicious
silver screen punch and you can make it
for your oscar viewing party as well
first you start off in the blender with
some frozen pink lemonade concentrate
mix in some pineapple juice some ginger
and frozen strawberries blend it until
it's smooth and then it just goes right
in your punch bowl
next add some vodka and this is just
gonna add a little punch to your punch
and we're going to put about a cup of
this in
and now the fun stuff the bubbly moet
chin don champagne
i'm just going to add the whole bottle
of this
that's the way to start a party
okay so pour this right into the bowl
and do this just before your guests
arrive that way it's still nice and
bubbly
and instead of ice to keep this drink
cold we're going to use frozen pineapple
slices i've just taken a pineapple cored
it sliced it into rings and frozen it
and that's going to be our ice
now i ladle it into some glasses
oh this looks so good and it smells good
too
and i'm gonna try some
toast to the oscars
delicious
another great cocktail to serve at your
oscar viewing party is the starlet so
we're gonna start off with some simple
syrup and this is just a mixture of
water and sugar that i've heated until
the sugar all dissolves so just about
half ounce of that and gonna add some
lime juice
and some mint
i love mint and drinks
and now i'm using a muddler but you
could also use a wooden spoon and you
just want to kind of break up the mint
leaves in there and that releases all
their flavor gets all that good minty
taste out of them
okay now add some ice to your cocktail
shaker
and some tequila
i told you this was a fun drink and i'm
using elderflower liqueur this just kind
of has a floral flavor with a hint of
sweetness
and we're just going to give this a good
shake so the ingredients get nice and
cold
okay so i'm going to pour that
into my glass
and then we're going to top it off with
some moet
champagne cocktails are really great way
to make any party go from kind of
ordinary to extraordinary and just the
pop of that cork kind of makes everybody
feel like it's a really special moment
okay
and pour that into the glass just until
it's full
and garnish this with just another sprig
of mint or you could put a lime wheel on
here or if you have star fruit that
would look good as well
and this is just a really nice light
drink it's really delicious cheers to
the oscars
and an oscar party just wouldn't be
complete without some oscar games
download ballots and have your guests
fill them out before the show gets
started then you can shine a spotlight
on the winner with a great gift like
moet's awards season gold bottle or an
official oscars poster
you're all set with food and drinks and
everything you need time for your guests
to arrive for the biggest night in
movies of the year have a fabulous party
cheers